- Human bodies are all
beautifully different,
and we're gonna prove it
by watching some TikToks.
- What's a really weird
thing that your body does,
that you're not sure
anybody else's body does.
- So I was just wondering,
if anybody else can make
their tongue disappear?
- Yeah look, now you see it.
Now you don't.
Wow.
Did it like fold back into her throat?
She must have an extended
soft palate or something,
that she's able to just
like put her tongue,
all the way back in her mouth.
(high energy music)
Oh no.
It's not doctors signatures.
That's potentially varicose veins.
That's actually a problem.
So veins, the way that they
work in comparison to arteries,
is they're thin walled and they
have little valves in them,
that prevent backflow.
Sometimes when veins swell
from an overabundance of blood,
or perhaps from gravity,
pooling, what have you,
they could sometimes get damaged,
and they don't return back
to their normal shape,
so they look like that.
(laughs) That's so cool. I
wanna be able to do that.
I can do it
Whenever people have unique
control of their bodies,
I get so jealous cause I cannot
do anything remotely special
except touch my nose with my tongue.
I can't anymore.
I used to be able to.
(lively music)
Interesting, yeah.
Lipedema is frequently
confused with a lymphedema.
Lymphedema is swelling
from the lymphatic system.
Lipedema is basically an
increase amount or accumulation,
of fat tissue in a specific area,
and it's not like that you
could lose that fat tissue.
- I have two uvulas.
(exclaims)
- It's actually just excess
skin at the back of my throat,
and it's quite uncomfortable
and has been for the last 12 years.
- I see it. It's almost like a skin tag,
but in the back of the throat,
it could easily pass for a second uvula.
- Did you know that spine circles,
can not only lubricate your spine,
but they can strengthen muscle
and tendon coordination.
- An accurate TikTok.
Absolutely do spine
circles. Like I do cat cow,
but this is like cat cow on steroids.
Do this. This is amazing.
If you're otherwise healthy,
and have no other medical injuries,
kind of got to be careful on this.
- I have three nostrils.
Told you.
- See, I wonder if this individual
has just a septum there,
like an extra septum meaning a separation.
And then it continues and merges
into one nasal passage way.
Or are there truly
three nasal passageways?
Cause I've never seen that before.
I wonder what an E-N-T
would say about this.
Can I do this? All right, I'm ready.
Oh wait. What?
No, that's not real.
I can't imagine that to be real.
There is a medical condition
where you have multiple pupils,
but not like a full iris at all.
- I was born with a
condition called ectrodactyly
- Oh, it's almost like a,
they call this sometimes a cleft hand,
almost like a cleft palate.
- I don't have my middle fingers,
which means yes, I cannot
flip someone off. Thank you.
- Oh, she's doing the Friends' joke.
- This finger for some reason just,
and then this one too.
- Well, that makes sense.
She has an extra joint there,
so she has extra mobility there.
So that's interesting.
- That's it.
I love my hands and I
think they're really cool.
- Love your differences.
(exclaims) Worm.
When I was on The Doctors
Show, we talked about this.
How you can get loiasis,
which is a type of parasitic
worm that can enter your eye.
There are treatments for this.
I can't believe they got it on camera,
this clearly though, it's nice.
- Let's test my spice limit again.
- Oh, I have zero spice limit,
so I already know I'm gonna lose.
- Takis.
- I don't know what a
Taki is. What's a Taki?
Holland/Cayanne pepper. (exclaims)
- Serrano.
- Remember the spiciness from
peppers comes from capsaicin.
It's the compound that actually triggers,
that burning sensation in your mouth.
No actual damage is happening,
but it's tricking your body,
into thinking it there's damage happening,
so your body's creating
all of these reactions,
like the sensation, the
sweating, the swelling.
I could never do this.
This is like extra and then
going one step past extra.
No, no, don't do it.
You know what all I'm
thinking about is like,
it's burning on its way in,
but it's also gonna burn on its way out.
- Fun fact. Did you know,
that removing caffeine from
your diet can help you lose...
- Please be accurate.
Please be accurate.
- Over 60% Of your will to live.
(laughs)
- Not accurate, but funny.
Quickly removing caffeine from your diet,
can cause withdrawal headaches.
(soft music)
To-make-a
To make a difference.
(laughs)
She got me up. For doc Dana
always coming in clutch.
He braids his armpit hair? I can do that.
Ow!
- That was pretty weird.
- No, it's not.
I can pull out my armpit hair too,
but it's not going to feel good.
- Think fast.
- Oh! Not fast enough.
- Listen! That child is
going to be a pro athlete.
(laughs)
- He just gets hit in the face.
That's me as a kid all the time.
I had the same little hoop just
in my like tiny one bedroom
apartment in Brooklyn, where
I used to dunk all the time.
And because it had a springy, like a rim,
I would dunk it and it would
chew right back into my face.
- I invented this peeing
aid when we need to pee,
we activate this, which
will help us to hold it.
We don't need to use our hands at all.
It also helps us to shake
a little. Very easy to use.
- Oh! Man.
That's gonna hurt. I don't
want it, I don't want it.
Blister. What am I looking at?
Blister blister. Oh,
blister that pop. Yeah
don't pop your blisters
because within the blister that's kind
of a sterile environment,
so you don't want to open
it up and create a potential
source of infection.
Cause remember immediately
underneath the blister,
like underneath the pocket of fluid,
you have sensitive skin
there that hasn't healed yet.
- This is super weird.
I can move my head.
- Ah, that's cool.
Your scalp actually has
muscles. That's normal.
Actually. Do you know
why goosebumps happen?
Do you know why hair
stands up on your skin ?
Because of muscles.
Is that cool?
- Okay. So I'm 20 years old
and I've never met anybody else
that's able to do this.
- Show us.
whoa.
- I can bend both my knees backwards
and I can take it to the side and bend it.
- Wow! She is really hyper
flexible. It's hypermobility,
not just in the knee joint,
but also in the hip joint as well.
Cause to do that whole rotation there,
I could see that causing a
significant problem medically
down the line.
That's why it's important that
your doctor understands the
risks that you face.
So therefore you require
individual care and individual
assessment of your risks to
prevent future problems or
decrease the likelihood of them.
(indistinct)
- What it looks like I'm
looking at here is potentially
clubbing of the distal phalanges.
It's an enlargement of the
furthest part of your finger,
where you actually have down
sloping of the nail as well.
This most commonly happens in
cancers related to the lung,
but it can happen with
heart disease as well.
Also some malabsorption conditions.
Also I'm talking about
secondary clubbing of the,
of the hands. If you have
primary clubbing of the hands,
that means you just happened
to be born like that.
And you actually don't have a problem.
Oh, I think this is called
syndactyly where two fingers are
actually attached and
never separated at birth.
It's a congenital situation.
Based on the movement there,
it looks like a surgical option
would be possible and still
retain motion of both fingers
based on how it was moving.
- I have been Vegan for two years
due to allergies, sensitivities,
and medical reasons I
have to start eating fish.
- I wonder why fish specifically.
I've never seen someone so
sad to have to eat fish.
- I'm really sad.
- Aw. I'm guessing she was
vegan for ethical reasons.
- I'm literally having a breakdown
over this piece of fish right now.
- I don't know who this person is
and I don't know if they're
acting here, but if they aren't,
I feel bad.
- Here
No.
Find a joint in my neck.
- Oh, wow.
Dangerous.
If you have hyperlaxity
like this in your neck,
imagine you're involved in a car accident.
You have a traditional whiplash
injury where you snap your
neck back and forth because you
were rear-ended huge problem
here because there's not enough
supportive tissue here to
prevent a serious, serious injury.
Ooh, splinter time, splinter time.
- Jake told me he had
a splinter in his foot.
- I hope this is a doctor doing this.
I can't really see what's
going on. Is that, oh,
that's a blade.
That's a type of blade
that we use in certain skin
procedures do like a shave biopsy.
- Oh my god!
- Oh wow.
Is that blood? I can't really see.
Oh, that is a serious, serious, serious.
I want to say one more time.
Serious splinter.
The first time I actually moved into my
home in Staten island.
I never had a big home.
Before that we lived in a
tiny box apartment for like a
decade. I ran across the
floor, this new wooden floor.
And I slid in my socks.
I had something like that go into my foot,
but it didn't go all the way
in. I was able to pull it out,
but it was the most
painful experience ever.
So from that moment on, I said,
I am never sliding on the
floor with socks again,
because I have a fear of that.
- Hope y'all understand me.
- (indistinct) answer your questions.
So what's that on your face, no offense.
It is called a metal rod.
When I got shot right here,
the bullet came up, my neck
- A bullet
- and my jaw shattered.
So they had to put these rods in my jaw
in hopes that my jaw
bone reconstruct itself.
- Well, it does.
The body does heal itself. I mean,
I don't know in this
specific instance, obviously,
but generally speaking,
the body does a fantastic
job of healing itself.
Imagine a bone breaks.
You put it together,
even though like you didn't
put any glue or anything,
it just starts healing.
Isn't that amazing?
- Hi , it's me Riri.
- Hi, Riri.
- I will show you the CPR.
I know all the CPR.
Duck is hurt.
Save the duck.
- No Riri you got to check
If the duck has a pulse, ask
the duck if it's alive first.
Call for help Riri.
That was really cute though.
Would sculpting breaks down cellulite.
Then we transfer the fat to the butt.
You really think you can just
move fat around in your body.
Imagine I'm like, oh,
this muscle is so nice.
You know what? Let's just put it here.
No, it doesn't work like that.
The reality of cellulite
is that it's near permanent
and you have to go
through drastic measures
to address it. Like laser procedures
or even surgical procedures.
So to say that like,
you're just going to do
this and then move the fat.
Come on now.
- Hey, what's up guys.
- How to make your lady juice
smell and tastes like heaven.
Is that the name of her concoction.
- Teach you how to make your
huha smell and taste amazing.
So it's all about the pH
depending on what you eat,
it can taste really bitter or
you can also smell and taste
fishy, which is not what you want.
- A vaginal odor that
has a fishy odor to it
does not come from eating fish.
Man. TikTok is so problematic.
First of all, a vagina
should smell like a vagina.
It shouldn't smell like peaches.
Like that's not what it's
supposed to smell like.
A healthy vaginal pH is
actually acidic to some degree.
And that's the normal vaginal
pH and changes in that
vaginal pH can change the odor,
but it's not the pH
that's changing the odor.
It's the pH that's changing
the microorganisms that live in
the vagina that changed the odor.
- Good morning.
I'm here for the interview.
- Ah, oh, you're hired.
- Excuse me. Yeah, you can have the job.
- Oh, I love this doctor.
This doctor actually has an
amazing story because I've read
that this doctor's heart stopped
and his wife actually saved his life
by doing chest compressions,
chest compressions,
chest compre- You know what?
After this video,
I'm going to email this doctor
and send him a chest
compressions merch shirt,
because I think it would
probably mean a lot more to him
than it does to me.
- What do you think a
typical workday looks like
for a primary care doctor.
- Fitting 12 hours of
appointments into eight hours
then going home and charting
until I fall asleep at my computer.
- So the only thing I
would change for myself,
there is fitting 14 hours of appointments
into 10 hours and charting
at my desk at work
before I fall asleep.
I can't go home.
Once I'm home I suck
at doing notes at home.
So I have to stay in the office
and sometimes it's so dark,
it's so late when I'm leaving.
Family medicine is an amazing,
amazing specialty. There's
so much good stuff to it.
But everything mentioned
here is so spot on.
- Did you have fun at the Doctor?
- They were measuring me.
- Aww. We measure the length of a baby.
The circumference of the
baby's head. We weigh the baby.
- They got me some stickers.
- I love stickers. I love
giving stickers away.
- Yeah I did have fun.
I do wanna go back to the doctor.
- In my head.
This is how all my pediatric
patients think of me.
It's definitely not the case.
- Let's go back to the doctor.
- The miracle of positive reinforcement.
- And they can give me some more stickers.
- How about the fact
that we're helping you
with your health? Huh?
It's not all about stickers.
I'm officially going on tour.
I never thought that this would happen.
Here are the cities that
I'm visiting in April.
I'm so excited to meet you guys.
I'm about to blow the
roof off these stages
by having a blast, educating,
staying happy and healthy.
So check out the tour, link
down below, get your tickets.
It's going to be a blast.
Like if you you're not going to be there,
you're going to miss out.
There's actually VIP tickets
available that are limited in
quantity, where you get
special merch items.
I may sign them. We'll
take a photo together.
We'll meet in person.
The tickets are limited in quantity too.
So get yours now before they get sold out,
I'm only doing these four
cities for now and click down
below. The link is right there.
Dr. Mike live.com.
And if you drink green tea or
you want to know more about
green tea, here are seven
factually interesting facts.
It's a fact,
a lot of green tea click
here and check that out.
As always stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)